he talks politics he's like a
commentator and he's really good and I'm
just wondering who he is and what he's
done I I end up watching everything he
does
folks folks I think you can subscribe to
his channel absolutely which I don't do
like I don't pay for it I get the free
feed oh you gotta be kidding me Howard
do you give him a like or anything do
you do anything I don't give anybody any
likes that when Howard Stern says I
love the content but I won't subscribe
for six bucks the minimum you can do is
hit the Subscribe button on YouTube help
us get to that 2 million and if you can
in all seriousness go to joinpakman.com
get yourself a membership you can use
the coupon code indicted again and uh
what what a day what a day